bienvenidos a 5 minutos conseguimos
algunas entrevistas en el marco de la
cumbre climática que se celebra de
manera virtual y semipresencial en
washington dc eeuu y nos acompaña a
rubén muñoz alcalde de la paz en mexico
alcalde gracias por estar con nosotros
en france 24 le pregunto en qué se va a
comprometer su ciudad para lograr
cumplir con la meta de neutralidad de
carbono para el año 2050
la paz
como municipio de la región de baja
california sur el méxico ha asumido
varios compromisos en su agenda
ambiental para contribuir con el cambio
climático
estamos hablando de economía circular
por ejemplo para el reaprovechamiento de
la basura como uno de los ejes
fundamentales del municipio pero hemos
avanzado en acciones muy concretas
hicimos el compromiso de plantar 50.000
árboles en la ciudad para que cada voto
que recibimos en el pasado proceso
electoral se convierta en un nuevo árbol
para las siguientes generaciones
comenzamos como el primer municipio de
mexico a generar energía alternativa y
hoy más del 80% de la energía que
consumen las oficinas municipales
provienen de energías fotovoltaicas
somos
el primer municipio mexicano que crea
una paramunicipal para venderle energía
fotovoltaica a la comisión federal de
electricidad en mexico pero además hemos
iniciado con la sustitución energética
para que los pozos de las comunidades
rurales que surten de agua potable ya no
consuman energía tradicional y a través
de paneles fotovoltaicos estemos hoy
dándole agua potable a las comunidades
con energía limpia
ahora alcalde hay una relación entre el
cambio climático y la migración en su
ciudad le pregunto cuál sería
cambio climático inmigración son dos
variables fundamentales que tenemos hoy
que revisar desde el punto de vista
regional en aquellas regiones que hay
cuidado de los recursos como son el agua
el medio ambiente los recursos naturales
tenemos comunidades ricas que se dedican
a la agricultura a la producción de
alimentos y que permiten el
sostenimiento comunitario cuando se
abusa de esos recursos comienzan por la
necesidad de buscar nuevas oportunidades
de empleo y de desarrollo económico este
proceso que es el gran fenómeno del
siglo 21 que es el proceso de la
migración por ello tener una agenda
verde para las regiones de nuestros
países de nuestras comunidades y
municipios nos va a permitir que
nuestros centros poblacionales
encuentren alternativas de desarrollo y
empleo en el municipio de la paz por
ejemplo el turismo es para nosotros la
fuente más importante
por ello nosotros desarrollamos en una
comunidad pesquera que estaba abandonada
llamada puerto chalé a tan sólo 157 km
de la capital del estado
un programa de rescate eco turístico
puerto chalet es el mayor centro de
avistamiento de la ballena gris y lo que
hicimos fue que los pescadores de esa
región para evitar que emigrarán
tuvieran una segunda alternativa a
través del ecoturismo les instalamos un
muelle para el transporte de los
turistas le pusimos fotoceldas a todas
las casas de los pescadores tenemos agua
con una planta desaladora que funciona
con energía solar y hoy por total es un
ejemplo de eco sustentabilidad
alcalde muy nuevos en ese sentido cómo
hacer de la lucha contra el cambio
climático algo atractivo para la
economía de la ciudad
el cambio climático tiene que generar
incentivos a la economía bonos verdes
para que no contaminemos
bonos de plástico neutralidad por
ejemplo para que los basureros en los
municipios y comunidades generen una
economía circular aprovechemos todo el
plástico en el reaprovechamiento
industrial que tenemos que hacer
convirtamos la basura en energía y con
la materia orgánica podamos generar
composta para el sector agrícola cuando
el cambio climático desarrolla regiones
con el respeto al medio ambiente no sólo
creamos comunidad
creamos arraigo y el cambio climático
entonces adquiere un valor económico
alcalde gracias por su tiempo ustedes
también gracias continúan con nosotros
[Música]